[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora passato versus futuro analogico
versus digitale e reale versus virtuale
nella società della comunicazione in cui
siamo immersi
anzi forse è meglio dire che siamo
sommersi ogni secondo della nostra vita
queste sono solo alcune delle dicotomie
che stanno alla base del dibattito in
ambito artistico e culturale
ma siamo davvero sicuri che si tratti di
dicotomia ovvero sono veramente universi
che si escludono a vicenda nel 1989
reach al sound forma nel fondatore di
ted affermava che l'edizione del fine
settimana del new york times conteneva
più informazioni di quante un cittadino
dell'inghilterra del xvii secolo avrebbe
potuto ricevere nell'intero arco della
propria vita 1989 2019 sono passati
trent'anni
il web è esploso i social proliferano ed
ognuno di noi è diventato un editore o
almeno un amplificatore di informazioni
informazioni che quando non sono
verificate e spesso sono fake news
non più tardi di cinque sei anni fa
nostra mamma
anzi vostra mamma no perché credo sia
mia mia coetanea mia mamma per per
affermare l'attendibilità di una notizia
esclamava sicura lo ha detto la tv
adesso dice l'ho letto su facebook nel
2008 quando gli ho aperto il mio profilo
facebook mia mamma pensava che fosse un
covo di voi e rischi di guardoni
adesso undici anni dopo sono io che devo
controllare lei
ma torniamo a noi la società della
comunicazione ci espone a ricevere una
enorme quantità di informazioni e questo
può causare il cosiddetto information
overload ovvero un sovraccarico
cognitivo che avviene quando ricevendo
appunto troppo informazioni non
riusciamo più a focalizzare la nostra
attenzione
non riusciamo a prendere una decisione
conseguente ora tutti noi siamo
potenzialmente esposti alla information
overload per farvi un esempio comune
quello della dipendenza da internet
uno dei casi in cui avviene o può
avvenire la dipendenza da internet e
quando una persona ha necessità di
trovare un informazione specifica per
poter poi prendere una decisione e
decide di andare sul web e va alla
ricerca di un'informazione andando sul
sito e poi non gli è sufficiente e
quindi va su un altro sito su un altro
sito ancora alla ricerca di sempre
maggiori dettagli e con una modalità
sempre più veloce fino a scaturire oa
poter scaturire nel cosiddetto
sovraccarico cognitivo che determina una
diminuzione dell'attenzione ed una
perdita della capacità di sintesi ed una
mancanza di analisi critica quello che
succede è che si può arrivare a nessuna
decisione
attenzione la information overload non è
da confondersi con il noto paradosso
dell'asino è un paradosso attribuita ad
un filosofo del 1300 giovanni buridano
che poi è stato ripreso successivamente
da illustri successori filosofi come
leibniz o come spinoza ma anche da
letterati come voltaire come il nostro
achille campanile
il paradosso recita così un asino
affamato ed assetato è accovacciato
esattamente tra due mucchi di fieno con
accanto ad ognuno un secchio d'acqua ma
non c'è niente che lo determina ad
andare da una parte piuttosto che
dall'altra
perciò resta fermo e muore
ora in questo caso la morte dell'asino
non è stata causata da un sovraccarico
cognitivo ovvero l'asino non ha ricevuto
troppe informazioni per cui non è stato
più in grado di prendere una decisione
ma è stata determinata dal fatto che il
suo cervello
messo alle prese con due scelte
equivalenti non potendo operare una
scelta decide di non decidere
ma torniamo a noi anche perché non sono
venuto qui per fare per darvi un esempio
live di information overload e d'altra
parte non ho voglia di fare la fine
dell'asino
oggi tutti voi
uscendo di casa e venendo qui in questo
teatro
avete preso una decisione e avete
compiuto un atto di condivisione sociale
ovvero avete marcato la vostra presenza
e la vostra partecipazione in un dato
momento specifico ora in questo momento
al 17 37 del 23 febbraio 2019 e in un
dato luogo fisico
qui in teatro all'interno del format the
next to throw ma d'altra parte se avesse
deciso di non venire di rimanere a casa
avreste mercato alla vostra assenza e la
vostra non partecipazione
torniamo quindi alle dicotomie iniziali
alle quali aggiungiamo queste ultime due
che abbiamo visto tutte queste dicotomie
rappresentano quelle di le tematiche che
si entra nel dibattito del grande tema
sulla diffusione e divulgazione del
patrimonio artistico e culturale
diciamo che rappresentano le parole e
concetti di quello che potremmo definire
l'alfabeto del futuro
nel racconto dell'arte prima che
iniziasse a parlare abbiamo visto un
video e abbiamo fatto un viaggio
indietro nel tempo di 500 anni
un viaggio virtuale grazie ad una
ricostruzione digitale basata però su
elementi storiografici e scientifici di
come appariva nel reale
roma nel rinascimento e più precisamente
nel 1508 l'anno in cui papa giulio ii
commissione a michelangelo buonarroti
quella che poi diventerà uno dei
capolavori dell'umanità la volta della
cappella sistina una serie di affreschi
di straordinaria bellezza che sono stati
realizzati grazie
ad un'opera di creatività artistica un
atto per antonomasia analogico
realizzati grazie alla maestria di
questo grande maestro artista totale
qual'era michelangelo buonarroti ed
abbiamo effettuato un viaggio nel
passato però con un punto di vista del
presente come se nel 1500 già esistesse
il drone uno strumento all'epoca del
futuro quindi nell'alfabeto del futuro
del racconto dell'arte è fondamentale il
racconto ed il linguaggio che vengono
utilizzati e la parola chiave è
contaminazione è e sarà contaminazione
ovvero le dicotomie che abbiamo visto
prima non saranno più così imposizione
dicotomica le parti si andranno ad unire
lu nell'altra i confini non saranno così
fissi ben delineati e stabiliti il
linguaggio dell'arte utilizzerà sempre
di più le tecnologie digitali e le fedi
zera diciamo saranno sempre più utili
quando dovranno raccontare con un
linguaggio del presente
le opere d'arte analogiche del passato
siano esse di pittura di scultura opere
teatrali opere letterarie
architettoniche e alcune tecnologie che
in realtà già oggi conosciamo e
utilizziamo ma che in futuro avranno
sicuramente un'evoluzione maggiore come
quella della realtà virtuale e quella
della realtà aumentata
saranno tanto più efficaci quanto più
riusciranno a restituirci il il senso
del presente di un passato ormai
scomparso e quindi le dicotomie si
confondono e si contaminano tra di loro
andando a creare qualche cosa di nuovo
all'interno però di queste dicotomia che
abbiamo visto oggi
io credo che ce ne sia una che valga la
pena a mantenere nella sua posizione
dicotomica e nello specifico mi
riferisco quella tra
presenza versus assenza e credo che
proprio qui che risiede alla sfida del
futuro ovvero qui troviamo il punto di
svolta tra analogico e digitale tra
reale e virtuale e non mi riferisco solo
al mondo dell'arte
quello che voglio dirvi che è importante
la presenza è importante vivere quelle
emozioni in modo fisico che potete
provare solo stando seduti uno accanto
all'altro ascoltando le emozioni e
l'energia che vi passa il proprio vicino
in platea oppure l'attore che sta
recitando vicino a voi
o magari qui sul palco
lasciate quindi che dirà il vi lascio
con una mia personale speranza la mia
speranza è che in futuro i vostri visi
vengano sempre meno illuminati dalla
luce del vostro smartphone
magari mentre state chattando con degli
amici o state condividendo delle foto è
vero state compiendo un'azione di
condivisione attraverso un mezzo
tecnologico ma è pur sempre una
situazione di assenza
io invece mi auguro che i vostri visi
siano illuminate sempre di più dalla
gioia e dallo stupore di vivere un atto
di condivisione sociale
un atto di presenza provando quelle
emozioni che solo l'arte il teatro
possono e devono continuare a regalarci
grazie
[Applauso]